the reason why I wanted to jump into
this fast and furious world is because a
I'm a fan of as well I'm a fan of these
movies and I and B the opportunity to
make an action film is something I've
always wanted to do and and the chance
to play you know in such a huge
playground was super exciting for me and
so I you know I give it a shot and I was
I felt very fortunate to be to be doing
it how do you put your stamp on
something your own personal stamp on
something that's existed in six previous
films well you know one of the things I
tried to do is you know I want to try
and honor all the great things that that
you know the previous filmmakers have
done before me and and so to keep it in
the same tone keep it sort of in the
same world but you know but try bring
some of the visual stamps you know
there's some of visual stuff that I love
aesthetically that is inherently to me
and to my filmmaking and you know for
example the kind of stuff I like to do
play with is you know have fun with the
camera work and I did bring some of that
cool camera work into this and and also
wanting to bring what I love from my
thriller genre background which is
suspense I love to bring suspends and
tension into a lot of the set pieces
here as much as I possibly could talk
about the scope and scale with each film
they've grown bigger and bigger and
it's just not all about the size but but
talk about the scope here you okay with
that one right okay for me it wasn't
about trying to top the previous movie
for the sake of topping the previous
movie in terms of the scope and the size
and the big action and all that for me
it was all about creating something that
we haven't quite seen before and so the
idea of like throwing these muscle cars
out on the back of a plane that was
exciting for me because I've never seen
anything like that before and cars
jumping from you know from skyscraper to
skyscraper that was something I've never
seen before
and even smaller more intimate sort of
fight action scenes where where where
you know Paul Walker's character Brian
fights with Tony Jaa's character and and
that they fully on a door and the doors
going down the stairs and it plays like
a sleigh ride you know so it's stuff
like that that uh that I really love
just visual things that we have not
quite seen before in an action film and
and that's what you know I wanted it
once at this movie to be about what made
Jason Statham's character Sean um I
think Jason Statham is probably the
strongest foe that are the strongest
protagonists that that our heroes in the
Fast and Furious franchise have ever
gone up against and and so Jason brings
with him obviously you know he is his
gravitas that he has built up in all
these other movies he you know he is an
action movie star in his own right and
so the idea of watching Jason go up
against the rock or Jason go up against
Vin Diesel at the end was super exciting
and and so so you know so it was I felt
very fortunate to have Jason in this
particular installment because he and I
get to be the new kids on the block and
and I get the chance to I create these
character with him you know that I
couldn't quite do with the other guys
because they already established but
with Jason I could do that and it was
fun and you
few other new kids on the block in coop
including I think the coolest man on the
planet Kurt Russell yes I feel extremely
fortunate to have worked with a living
legend on this film mr. Kurt Russell he
hews system he's like one of the
greatest guys I grew up on his films you
know I love all the different kind of
ease that he's done and you know to have
work with them you know people say it's
best not to work with your heroes
because you might be disappointed that
wasn't the case
Kurt Russell was truly truly a great
person he was so awesome to work with
and he was so professional to work with
as well and I you know I just could not
say enough nice of things about that
dude naturally oh my god I I feel very
fortunate to have worked with such a
beautiful human being and such a
beautiful soul as well natalie is not
only gorgeous on the outside she's
beautiful on the inside as well I love
how street sweet and innocent she is and
I think she brings a lot of of that
innocence to the character that the
character kind of needed you know she's
someone who's very smart you know and so
much it was a bit on the outside a bit
on the fringe of society but yet kind of
you know like young and innocent and
enough to kind of be manipulated by
these greater forces around them and I
think that's a reason why her character
really took a liking to to to our heroes
is because she can see them for who they
are
she feel the truth that these guys have
real real they are and and even though
in a lot of ways they're bandits but
they're truly they're they they're
thieves with honor and and I think at
the end of the day her character kind of
blends in with them and she she becomes
part of the family she's used to
traveling to a lot of different amazing
locations in the
this one might be the winner she talked
about going to Abu Dhabi and what that
brought to your film yeah I really think
you know the the different locations in
this film really gives it a very sort of
woolly quality you know so we start off
in Los Angeles then you know then we
track to a little bit to Tokyo and in
terms of story and then then we finally
go to Abu Dhabi and I think it's
incredible it's incredible because it's
such a beautiful visual contrast because
one of the things I wanted to do from a
storytelling standpoint was I wanted you
know that sort of classic sunny days of
Los Angeles you know that very very sort
of like outdoorsy Beach culture of LA
but then then I'll characters then hit
up the mountains of Azerbaijan where I
want that to be you know colder you know
to be more mutant of colors up in the
you know up in the mountain ranges there
and then and to contrast that with like
the harsh beautiful orange saturated
deserts of the United United Arab
Emirates was for me as a filmmaker is
such an exciting thing to do to visually
play with the different color palettes
and then showing you know the rest of
the world what Abu Dhabi is like was
really exciting I never knew that that
part of the wall had such a huge
interest and so it's just such a huge
culture in in cars and and they love The
Fast and Furious franchise and so it was
very fun for us to go there to to to
play in their world
and there was such respectful people to
have us there as well
you